هذه التعليقات تثير ضجة كبيرة في
إسرائيل ليس فقط بسبب ما قاله ترامب
ولكن بسبب ما قاله
زعيم المعارضة بنيامين نتنياهو
رداً على ذلك ، قال ترامب للصحفي
مراجعة باراك إنه شعر بالخيانة من قبل
نتنياهو بعد أن اتصل بجو بايدن
لتهنئته بعد فوزه في
قال ترامب في انتخابات نوفمبر 2020 إنه
شعر بالخيانة بسبب كل ما
شعر أنه فعله خلال إدارته
لصالح إسرائيل ، أشياء مثل الاعتراف
بالقدس كعاصمة لإسرائيل
والاعتراف بالسيادة الإسرائيلية على
مرتفعات الجولان ، قال ترامب إنه
كان مبكرًا ، فلنضع الأمر على هذا النحو.
لم أتحدث معه في وقت مبكر جدًا عن معظم قادة العالم ، لم
أتحدث معه منذ ذلك الحين ، كانت هذه الكلمات القاسية
بالتأكيد تثير الانتباه هنا في إسرائيل ولكن التحقق السريع من
الحقائق ، لم يكن نتنياهو في الواقع
مبكرًا جدًا في الاتصال بجو بايدن
لتهنئته  قبل أسبوعين من إجراء تلك
المكالمة الهاتفية ، تسبب ذلك التأخير في
بعض الانتقادات على الإنترنت  Anyahu في إسرائيل
بعد ساعات قليلة من ظهور هذه التعليقات
كتب بنيامين نتنياهو في بيان إنني
أقدر عاليا
مساهمات الرئيس ترامب الكبيرة
لإسرائيل وأمنها ، كما أنني أقدر
أهمية التحالف القوي
بين إسرائيل والولايات المتحدة ،
وبالتالي كان من المهم  بالنسبة لي
لتهنئة الرئيس القادم ، يمكنك
أن تقول من هذا البيان أن
نتنياهو يحاول أن يقطع خطًا رفيعًا
بين محاولة إبقاء جماهير ترامب
سعداء التي يوجد الكثيرون في
الولايات المتحدة ، ولكن أيضًا محاولة
حماية تطلعاته السياسية المستقبلية.
قال مرارًا وتكرارًا
إنه يخطط للعودة إلى مكتب
رئيس الوزراء ، وإذا فعل ذلك
فسيكون من المهم جدًا أن تكون لديه علاقة قوية
مع الولايات المتحدة
بغض النظر عن من هو الرئيس.